[Music]
do you have a message for brittany i
would say stay strong
um hold your ground we will pray for you
and i hope she gets what she deserves
which is her freedom
britney and bsb both did their
residencies at planet hollywood and now
the boys are coming back
[Music]
i think people really coming out of this
pandemic and coming out of
sort of this like dark time everyone
wants to get out
starting november 11th a very backstreet
christmas party will have a limited
engagement of 12
shows at planet hollywood resort and
casino and expect their very first
christmas album later this year
then their dna tour returns to the road
in 2022
but what about that recent boy band
mashup backsync
[Applause]
howie and bryan and kevin what did you
think when you heard about back sync
i asked tell me why no just i mean i
didn't know about it
till i saw it on social media and i was
like oh my god they're
trying to be back again i don't know
when we were doing our sound check you
know lance was actually kind of was kind
of funny he didn't know the words to
you know our song all the way through
and it's like
so we kind of had to have a little
prompter up there just to just to be
safe
a little teleprompter they're open to
another collab and
one thing's for sure the boys plan to be
around for a long time
we want to be the rolling stones of pop
music all in their 40s all looking good
and
each of these guys are proud dads are
all the families
coming to the show oh yeah yeah
[Music]